Speaker 1: We do have a new poll in which Joe
Biden is leading Donald Trump by four points.
This is a hypothetical 2024 general election poll.
This is a poll that assumes Trump's the Republican
nominee. Biden is the Democratic nominee and
the election were held today. In this poll,
Quinnipiac Biden leads Trump 48 to 44. Trump
support has dropped two points since Trump was
since the last time this poll was done in
late May. I like to get a more general look
at polling. If we look at the best rated
polls, B-plus and higher. We have a recent
YouGov poll. That poll says Biden and Trump
are actually tied among registered voters,
with Trump leading by one among all adults. We
then have the A-minus rated Quinnipiac poll, the
one I just described to you. It has Biden ahead
of Trump by four. And then we have an A-minus.
Suffolk University poll, which has Biden leading
DeSantis by seven. And Biden leading Trump by two.
What we can say at this point is that there is
a really big red flag. And the red flag isn't
Joe Biden's winning or Biden's losing or whatever
the red flag is. Biden has done a number of good
things as far as presidents are concerned. We have
a stable economy at worst, if not a solid economy.
Trump has been arrested multiple times. Lies
constantly fundraises on. GRift is facing all
sorts of different problems after losing for the
Republican Party in 2018, 2020 and pushing them
to lose or not win by as much as they should
have in 2022. And given all of that. Biden's
only winning by 1 to 3 or four. That's the
red flag. This if this country made sense.
If voters reacted sensibly and soberly and
thoughtfully to the facts of the world,
Joe Biden would be leading at minimum by double
digits. And so to anybody who's looking at
this current election and saying, oh, this is
they're just these Republicans aren't going to
win. There's no way Trump can win. There's
no way this country would reelect Trump.
The polling, even if you believe right,
like the best one of these polls,
the strongest one of these polls is Biden
leading Trump by four. Even if you believe that.
It is an absolute and total horror show, and we
should all be very much aware that Trump could
win. And we need to activate any tool we have
to prevent that from happening. And of course,
by the way, I mean any illegal tool, including
voter turnout, campaigning, debate prep,
surrogates, what all of the legal things, all
of the legal things, as always, as if I even
really have to clarify that scary stuff on tape
showing national secrets to guests at his resort.
And the best poll we can find has him down
four. Just absolutely horrifying stuff.